[Musique]
voir les enfants bros
quelle part fo elles ont pour moi ces
belles rosenau selon patron ce sont les
premières roses de mort aux yeux et je
les apporte à mes petits jeunes ont les
seuls
pomme pop-up hop hop hop
hop hop hop
bon ce
[Musique]
sont des roses éclats de rose de mou
rozier le problème
[Musique]
voyons combien y en as tu du color c'est
bien je ne vous dis pas bravo mince
alors
nicolas en voilà
et ben non
[Musique]
du avec cela ça fait
long feu
4 ça fait quatre hausses
dans la chanson oui comme dans la
chanson
[Musique]
manger à quatre fleurs pourront aussi à
quatre fleurs d'une charmante aux
couleurs quand la quille est allée des
eaux le pelouse ou quand la nuit est
d'arriver mais quatre ferme ont dansé
[Musique]
mais
c'est fini de 4 cornichons n'ont
d'autres champignons non comme trop beau
turon
même mois et les et mes yeux mes boutons
de rose dans ce tout les 4 entre eux
arrivent à temps merveilleux quand le
sommeil élevées des rouges
cela leur bout du nez dans la rosée
parthenay me voir bouger pour le reste
la journée
et vous les petits vous vous et des
barbouzes ou wim annonce et on s'est
même laver les dents orf hollow ou l'eee
pad nicolas nous et merci pour ces
belles rouille là j'ai été à l'honneur
je ne nuis
[Musique]
nicolas tort bien dit sar
alors nounours on attend sur la rom du
rosier pas trop vous vous êtes bien
amusés ou y mais vous savez ils sont
très sages tant mieux allons en route
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher est fait pour
[Musique]